Didier Drogba socratesse deux exemples
parmi d'autres de l'engagement des
footballeurs sur le terrain politique à
travers cette série les rebelles du foot
écrite et réalisés par Gilles Perez et
Gilles Rohff et c'est cette relation
entre footballeur et politique dont nous
allons débattre maintenant avec nos
invités présents sur ce plateau de débat
doc Jean-Baptiste Guégan et parmi nous
pour commencer bienvenue à vous vous
êtes enseignants spécialiste en
géopolitique du sport et auteur de la
République du foot pas le même parti
mais la même passion c'est un ouvrage
que vous avez coécrit avec Clément
perngnat et publié chez aurora vicash
doraso est également avec nous bienvenue
à vous les amateurs du foot vous
connaissent bien et pour cause vous
comptez 18 sélections en équipe de
France vous êtes passé par le Havre
l'Olympique Lyonnais les Girondins de
Bordeaux le Milan AC le
Paris-Saint-Germain deux types de
champion de France avec l'Olympique
Lyonnais une carrière qui s'achèvera en
2007 avant que vous deveniez consultant
télé pour la chaîne l'équipe et aussi
Canal+ Afrique et puis en 2019 vous êtes
présenté aux municipales dans le dixième
arrondissement de Paris sur une liste
soutenue par et les filles et puis enfin
si Yanni d'Alma est avec nous bienvenue
à vous vous êtes journaliste au
quotidien l'équipe spécialisée bien sûr
ça tombe bien dans la couverture du
football on vient de voir Drogba Socrate
voilà deux grandes figures à la fois du
foot et de footballeur qui sont
évidemment immiscés sur le terrain
politique c'était tout le thème des deux
épisodes qu'on vient de voir là on parle
d'exception ou vous pouvez nous dire oui
il y en a beaucoup d'autres des
footballeurs qui sont investis sur le
terrain politique il y a peut-être des
noms d'ailleurs qui vous viennent
immédiatement à l'esprit en dehors de
Drogba et socratesse j'ai envie de dire
asso parce que c'est le premier
finalement
dans une certaine mesure la fin de
l'aventure au Paris Saint-Germain par
exemple je crois que ça se termine par
un licenciement c'est une première et et
ça montre aussi que il y a un droit du
travail à faire respecter et je sais pas
si tu t'es retrouvé face au club à un
moment si on trouvait ça mais ça dit
quelque chose aussi ce qui est assez
intéressant c'est qu'on voit
qu'aujourd'hui une bonne partie des
footballeurs ne s'engagent pas ou reste
en retrait d'abord parce que leur
contrat les blocs on aimerait qu'ils
s'engagent davantage et on a du mal à
voir ça en tout cas en France on le voit
à l'étranger on a vu des beaucoup de
joueurs iraniens mais pas seulement
prendre position contre la Coupe du
Monde au Qatar aujourd'hui il y a plutôt
une tendance à la réserve et une vraie
demande sociale de voir ses footballeurs
s'engagés parce qu'ils sont les portes
voies de quelque chose le premier homme
politique de France finalement le plus
écouté celui qui est le plus visible
c'est qu'il allait Mbappé aujourd'hui
Didier Drogba il s'exprime devant la
télévision et wardenne on a gardé cet
extrait on va le revoir tout de suite on
en parle après le seul pays le seul pays
de l'Afrique
tu as toutes ces richesses ne peut pas
sombrer dans la guerre comme ça s'il
vous plaît déposez tous les armes faites
les élections organiser les élections et
tout ira du mieux on veut s'amuser
arrêtez vos fusils
on veut s'amuser arrêtez vos fils
là on est en 2005 la Côte d'Ivoire vient
de se qualifier pour la Coupe du Monde
de 2006 Didier Drogba profite évidemment
de cette caméra de la télévision
ivoirienne qui est dans les vestiaires
pour passer ce message de réconciliation
le football c'est le sport populaire
numéro 1 au monde ces joueurs sont hyper
médiatisés aujourd'hui on se dit que
tous les ingrédients sont là pour faire
passer des messages politiques
effectivement sont des joueurs d'impact
on le voit aussi avec Sadio Mané on le
voit finalement avec quantité de joueurs
même de manière négative nous de
certaines prises de position au joueur
je pense à Karim Benzema avant
finalement la réconciliation avec Didier
Deschamps on est face à des acteurs
aujourd'hui médiatique incontournables
il y a plus de 50% finalement aux
informations qui parlent de sport et le
premier des sports c'est le football
donc dès qu'un footballeur prend la
parole on l'entend on l'écoute parfois
on le suit et là vous êtes sur un très
bon exemple c'est à dire que là on peut
par le football en faisant entendre sa
voix rassembler les peuples en tout cas
apaiser les tensions sont des vrais
leaders positifs et ça on n'est pas
assez en avant des cages de rasso c'est
vrai que j'ai hésité à vous présenter
comme vous aussi un rebelle du foot vous
êtes à rebelle du foot dans votre esprit
vous vous différenciez de vos anciens
collègues footballeurs professionnels
sur ce terrain non pas du tout je suis
un joueur de foot c'est ce qui me
caractérise qui m'identifie certaines
manières après c'est vrai que ma fin de
carrière elle passe par un licenciement
et quand j'y repense aujourd'hui je le
regrette pas je m'en serais bien passé
sur le moment parce qu'après j'ai arrêté
mais je me suis opposé à ma direction
voilà je dis pas d'accord avec elle je
suis allé au bout du truc et j'ai été
licencié parce que je suis un salarié
d'une entreprise là ça allait riche
célèbre privilégié mais je reste un
salarié mon contrat a été se termin
j'avais 33 ans j'avais plus de valeur
marchande ils ont pas hésité à me virer
alors que alors que ils étaient en tort
est-ce que d'une certaine manière quand
on porte le maillot de l'équipe de
France quand on porte le maillot d'un
club c'est compliqué d'exprimer une idée
une revendication politique durant sa
carrière c'est compliqué même pas
souhaité on vous le fait payer de façon
très dure mais moi je crois que quand on
nous donne la parole si on a une
responsabilité à la prendre et à dire
des choses récemment il y a plein de de
personnes très importantes Colin
capernic a posé la terre sur le football
américain mais il l'a fait jusqu'à
perdre son travail à des gerberg a
décidé de ne pas aller jouer avec
l'équipe nationale elle a pas voilà elle
a ses mises en difficulté elle est toute
seule mais elle y est allée les joueurs
de foot de l'équipe de France récemment
on revu leur le droit à l'image la
convention de droit à l'image ils ont
gagné donc on peut revendiquer pendant
sa période de sa carrière sa carrière
après je leur
je impose pas de le faire parce que moi
je le fais aujourd'hui parce que je suis
après ma carrière et c'est plus facile
il y a d'autres exemples qui vous
viennent à l'esprit peut-être récent
d'ailleurs de d'engagement de de
footballeur ou de footballeuse bien sûr
sur le terrain politique
qui a été Ballon d'Or en 2019 après la
victoire des américaines à la Coupe du
monde et elle pour le coup elles ont un
engagement qui est pendant leur carrière
mais elles le font aussi parce qu'elles
ont beaucoup gagné et que leurs
résultats sur leur sur le terrain leur
donne la légitimité de parler et de
réclamer l'égalité avec les hommes
qu'elle n'avaient pas elles se sont
battues elles n'ont pas hésité à aller
devant les tribunaux face à leur
fédération
c'est quelque chose qu'on voit peut-être
très peu je pense que c'est aussi une
question de culture peut-être que dans
le football français ça se fait moins de
s'exprimer d'aller sur le terrain
politique on le voit souvent à
l'étranger Vikash a évoqué le cas
d'agber qui est très courageux
effectivement dire non à la sélection
alors qu'elle avait quoi 22 23 ans
du courage faut du cran pour le faire
quand les joueuses américaines se ligue
contre leur fédération bah voilà faut
avoir du courage pour le faire on l'a vu
en Espagne aussi récemment les
footballeuses espagnoles on les a
qualifiés de 15 rebelles se sont élevés
contre leur sélectionneur parce qu'elles
estimaient que leurs conditions de
travail n'allait pas en sélection et
pour le coup ce sont des joueuses
actuels dont Alexia potéas qui a été
élue ballon d'or à deux reprises donc
effectivement on voit qu'il y a des
joueuses des joueurs qui osent se
soulever en Espagne encore il y a une
grève de joueuse aussi pour demander
qu'elles aient une convention collective
qui était pas le cas en France on n'a
pas de convention collective dans le
football féminin et on n'a pas eu de
grève générale du championnat de France
pour le réclamer donc je pense que c'est
plus une question de de mentalité aussi
des footballeurs et des footballeuses
Mégane rapido engagé donc sur le terrain
de l'égalité des salaires entre les
footballeurs et les footballeuses
entre le moralisme aussi elle a mis
genou à terre
bien sûr du côté des footballeuses il y
a déjà la question de la maternelle bien
entendu c'est à dire que aujourd'hui
quand vous êtes une femme et que vous
exercez comme métier le métier de
footballeuse vous avez pas le droit de
tomber enceinte parce que dans certains
sports alors c'est un peu moins vrai
dans le foot mais la question se pose on
accepte difficilement que vous arrêtiez
votre carrière pendant un an un an et
demi ce qui est le droit général ça
c'est compliqué puis elle a aussi la
question de l'homophobie c'est à dire
que l'homosexualité dans le sport a
notamment dans le football féminin comme
comme masculin reste encore un problème
et on attend encore un coming out
masculin on a eu
la possibilité d'en avoir ça c'est pas
produit on attend un leader finalement
qui soit capable de porter ce combat là
et qui ouvre finalement des portes pour
tous les autres ça pour l'instant c'est
vraiment deux causes qu'on voit pas
avancer
le combat actuel vous vous le menez
alors évidemment à propos du Qatar
contre la FIFA avec cette tribune
publiée dans le quotidien Libération
c'était il y a pas très longtemps
c'était le premier novembre 2022 mondial
au Qatar footballeur nous aussi on se
lève et on se casse voilà c'est le titre
de cette tribune qu'est-ce que vous
reprochez exactement la FIFA peut-être
même au-delà de la Coupe du Monde du
Qatar dont on va reparler assez
largement tout à l'heure
le monopole déjà de la FIFA
ça nous fait croire aussi qu'elle
organise le football et qu'elle est la
seule à le faire à pouvoir le faire
alors que par exemple la Ligue fermée
des dirigeants de grands clubs qui
veulent faire une ligne fermée le Real
etc prouve qu'en fait on pourrait faire
autrement c'est parce que je soutiens
mais par contre il y a plein de lits
comme la FSGT par exemple en France qui
fait un autre football donc on peut
sortir des fédérations FFF comme de la
FIFA je pense que la FIFA aussi elle a
priori comme objectif
principal c'est de gagner beaucoup
d'argent de faire beaucoup d'argent sans
respecter les droits sociaux les les
sans lutter contre les discriminations
non plus donc moi je pense qu'on peut
organiser un autre football et il faut
sortir la FIFA et je pense que les jours
de foot doivent s'impliquer un maximum
il pourrait de rentrer encore
organisation en cours réalisation
prendre une plus grosse phare du gâteau
et la redistribuer parce qu'en fait
aujourd'hui il y a des gros salaires
donc moi j'invite les footballeurs à ce
à se bouger
bien sûr vous dites désobéir c'est
commencer à rêver se souvenir de la
démocratie corinthienne du docteur
Socratès ça tombe bien on a revu cette
évidemment ce qu'a fait socratesse au
sein de son club avec Corinthiens et
ensuite vous dites rêver d'un sport ou
les footballeurs les footballeuses
eux-mêmes se chargeraient d'organiser le
football le développerait le poids du
raie un football meilleur un football
qui revient au footballeur un football
sans FIFA
oui c'est un vrai ce programme mais par
exemple moi je pense que les
footballeurs devraient se créer un autre
syndicat que l'UNFP aujourd'hui un
syndicat qui les défendrait par exemple
contre le racisme il sait rien passé la
NFC pour appeler ce que c'est l'UNFP
c'est syndicat de footballeurs auquel
j'ai adhéré pendant 15 ans qu'il n'a pas
de protéger défendu quand j'étais
licencié donc voilà les footballeurs
aujourd'hui par exemple contre le
racisme c'est collectivement qu'il doit
réagir contre d'échec chair je crois et
PSG ils ont décidé de sortir du terrain
pour une fois c'est pas un seul joueur
c'est toute l'équipe les deux équipes et
bah la FIFA a plié est obligé de de déjà
de ne pas les mettre à cœur en mettant
des amandes et des discussions et
d'aller voir
ça aussi que finalement ça ne respire
pas forcément sur ce terrain là parce
que l'afficha sanctionne
systématiquement si un joueur ou une
équipe marque une forme de de résistance
de revendication sur un terrain de
football aujourd'hui lors d'une
compétition officielle ça s'appuie sur
ce qu'on appelle la politique du sport
ce fameux mythe qui est extrêmement
efficace surtout très facile à mobiliser
ça consiste à dire on fait surtout pas
de politique on veut surtout pas faire
de politique il faut à tout prix qu'on
reste en dehors de la politique ce qui
arrange finalement les acteurs comme la
FIFA parce que du coup ils ne prennent
pas position et à chaque fois qu'elle a
possibilité de faire quelque chose
surtout pas alors on fait la politique
c'est le débat aussi qui a eu avec les
javel là sur le port du voile pour en
compétition c'est vrai que la FIFA donne
aux associations donc par exemple à la
Fédération Française de Football le
choix ou non d'accepter le port du voile
pour les joueuses donc dans certains
pays c'est autorisé en revanche en
France l'article 1 de la du règlement de
la Fédération Française de Football
l'autorise pas donc le règlement de la
Fédération Française de Football est en
fin en contradiction avec celui de la
FIFA et en fait il y a il y a un point
un peu flou là donc c'est devant le
Conseil d'État ça devrait être réglé
peut-être dans les mois à venir mais en
tout cas on a ce truc aussi de c'est
aussi une des revendications des
joueuses et peut-être que elle pourrait
comme le dit Vikash c'est peut-être les
joueurs et les joueuses qui pourraient
décider de si on peut jouer avec un
voile si on peut pas si on sort de ce de
ce processus qui est actuel ou c'est
effectivement la Fédération Française
qui décide avec ses règlements et donc
les jabeux ça veut jouer au foot en
compétition elles peuvent pas le faire
est-ce que vous êtes un nostalgique de
de cette fameuse démocratie des
Corinthiens ce qu'on a vu dans ce
documentaire avec Socrate une forme
d'autogestion qui a été mise en place
dans dans ce club pendant quelques
années
en pleine dictature donc brésilienne
pour lutter contre l'autorité du club
les patrons du club il décide de voter
tout voilà les joueurs un homme une voix
même salaire pour tout le monde et ils
ont gagné de championnat paolista ils
sont rentrés en finale de de de
du championnat avec marqué la victoire
mais toujours en démocratie c'était
incroyable d'ailleurs le le moment le
plus beau des des récents Ballon d'Or
c'est le moment Rahi vient rendre
hommage à son frère c'est incroyable ce
qu'ils ont fait ces gens-là grâce au
football donc ouais j'invite les joueurs
de foot à se mobiliser ensemble
collectivement quand il va
collectivement Mégane Rapin des
collectivement qu'elle gagne l'autre
fois Mbappé c'est parce que les autres
joueurs le rejoignent et ils y vont
ensemble et là on gagne parce qu'on est
fort en fait les footballeurs mais seul
on perd quand Neymar critique les
arbitres il prend 3 matchs de suspension
quand Messi meilleur joueur du monde
critique ça fédération il prend 4 matchs
de suspension on matraque parfois si ça
peut être justifié d'être sanctionné
mais moi je pense qu'on doit se bouger
et les joueurs qui sont là sont très
forts le racisme dans le football vous
n'avez pas parlé là tout à l'heure vous
l'avez mis mais est-ce qu'il y a pas
manières à matière tout même à
s'attarder sur la lutte contre le
racisme dans le football aujourd'hui à
travers l'action de joueurs sur le
terrain qui quittent parfois le terrain
pour lutter contre ce racisme alors ce
qui est assez intéressant c'est que l'un
des seuls domaines finalement d'activité
aujourd'hui où vous avez une
représentation de la diversité c'est le
sport et à forceur le football c'est le
seul endroit vous avez une
représentation qui ressemble à la France
d'aujourd'hui
sur le terrain sur le terrain dehors et
encore moins dans les instances que les
instances c'est une blague je parle même
pas des dans les instances c'est une
blague c'est ce que il suffit de
regarder par exemple le nombre de femmes
le nombre de personnes issues de la
diversité le nom de personne issues de
la diversité qui sont des femmes c'est
simple il y en a pas d'accord donc c'est
aussi rapide que ça donc ça pose la
question aussi de ce que le football
peut faire avancer aujourd'hui quand on
voit quand on se souvient de la France
de 98 quand on se souvient de la France
de 2018 on a avancé
la frange ça empêche pas qu'on est 30%
de la France qui soit en coréeenne mais
derrière on a une France qui bouge on a
une France qui s'accepte de plus en plus
le football est un des facteurs qui
permet ça qui permet justement de
changer les représentations des gens et
c'est juste la couleur ça pas seulement
été un slogan au moment de cette
victoire en Coupe du monde ça ça a
perduré et gérer ça infusé ça a pas
perdu parce que c'est une construction
après ce qui est intéressant avec
justement ce moment-là c'est que ça a
permis aussi à des gens qui ont
maintenant 40 ans qui avaient 20 ans à
l'époque où qui était plus jeune de se
dire que c'était possible et ça c'était
même pas acquis de voir un moment donné
un peu Plantier se rassembler en disant
que il est des Zidane allait être celui
qu'on allait suivre on se félicitant
aussi du Ballon d'Or de Karim Benzema ça
il y a 30 ans c'était pas du domaine du
possible aujourd'hui on voit que
l'équipe de France à la campagne le
parcours de de l'immigration en France
et de sa diversité et en l'occurrence
c'est un vrai atout maintenant je suis
d'accord on est on est pas allé assez
loin on n'est pas allé vous n'êtes pas
tout à fait d'accord avec ça j'ai trouvé
ça enfin avec le recul effectivement sur
le coup la France black bombers c'était
beau c'était plein de plein de belles
promesses mais c'est un peu fumeux quand
on avec le recul quand on voit
maintenant effectivement le football sur
le terrain c'est hyper divers mais une
fois qu'on arrive dans les postes
d'entraîneur dans les poses de direction
dans les instances cette diversité a
disparaît en fait et moi je pense qu'on
a beaucoup surfé sur ce sur ce mythe et
finalement quand on met on fait un petit
pas de côté on voit que c'était pas
totalement concrète totalement vrai
c'est là dessus quelques réticences moi
est-ce que ça vous est venu à l'esprit
pendant un match de football
suite à une insulte raciste de quitter
le terrain d'inciter peut-être vos cups
ou parce qu'un de vos coéquipiers à lui
fait l'objet d'une insulter raciste donc
quitter un terrain ça m'est jamais
arrivé de voilà ça a dû arriver j'ai
peut-être pas entendu mais en Italie ça
arrive par exemple en Italie mais
mon premier engagement quand je me
présente aux élections dans le 18e si je
suis un homme issu de l'immigration des
classes populaires et qui mène une tête
de liste dans le 18e arrondissement je
suis pas en deuxième de liste je suis
pas en 3e de lit absolument tête de
liste j'invite aussi les footballeurs à
aller tropeter les postes de pouvoir
c'est difficile parce que c'est pas
organisé pour qu'on puisse y arriver on
y pense pas aussi on nous fait croire
que nous on est bien à courir et tant
qu'on n'est pas représenté dans les
instances on se sent pas représenté donc
évidemment et ceux qui sont dans les
instances ne sont pas touchés par le
racisme ou l'homophobie ou le sexisme
donc évidemment ils vont rien faire il
va rien se passer tant qu'on y va pas
donc il faut présenter des listes à la
FFF à la FIFA etc et si elle est trop
ses postes pouvoir et de décision on
décide jamais nous les footballeurs on
n'est jamais consultés pour le Qatar
encore une fois des footballeurs qui
s'impliquent dans la vie politique après
leur carrière il y en a eu tout de même
un certain nombre bah là le président du
Liberia aujourd'hui qui est un ancien
footballeur ou ea par exemple ouais on
peut penser aussi à chenko qui c'est
l'ancien joueur du Milan AC ancien
joueur dynamote qui a là depuis quelques
mois porte un bout de bras aussi
l'effort de guerre en Ukraine en allant
à chaque fois qu'il le peut parler de la
cause il était sur le plateau du Ballon
d'Or on voit aussi un salut Manet
beaucoup plus discret mais qui fait
énormément de Liverpool on va le
rappeler pour ceux qui ne connaîtraient
pas trop le football alors maintenant il
est au Bayern voilà ancien joueur de
livres de Liverpool qui fait énormément
justement pour son pays surtout pour son
village ce qu'on voit c'est
qu'aujourd'hui des footballeurs engagés
il y en a beaucoup
beaucoup préfèrent un engagement local
redonner finalement
soit leur communauté soit à la ville
finalement dont ils sont issus ou alors
ils le font très discrètement on a
beaucoup de gens d'équipe de France par
exemple qui donne leur prime de match et
qui ne tirent pas publicité justement de
ces noms là engagement politique
caritatives il y a une porosité aussi
entre entre les deux on peut aider les
jeunes on peut aider les plus démunis on
peut aider la lutte contre le racisme
un engagement il n'a pas besoin d'être
sur un terrain de football pour un
footballeur aujourd'hui il y a mille
manières de s'engager vis-à-vis de la
société et ensuite je pense que on
s'adresse aussi à de très jeunes hommes
et que la conscience politique avait
peut-être un petit peu de temps aussi à
venir et moi je trouve ça bien déjà qui
commence peut-être par un engagement
local après qui prête conscience du
milieu dans lequel ils évoluent
peut-être que leur conscience politique
évolue aussi enfin moi je trouve ça
parfois un peu compliqué qu'on les force
à s'exprimer sur des sujets en plus qui
vont pas forcément maîtriser ou qui les
intéressent pas forcément tout ça parce
qu'ils ont de la lumière qu'ils ont de
la gloire et que il y a injonction à
prendre position s'il le sentent tant
mieux et s'il peut pas porter quelque
chose ben ça c'est très bien après faut
pas qu'il soit obligé de le faire parce
qu'ils ont un nom et parce que voilà
enfin ce serait même contre-productif si
effectivement ce qu'ils ont à dire et
pas intéressant et apportent pas
grand-chose ensuite je pense que voilà
il faut pas oublier que même dans enfin
ça reste des êtres humains avant tout et
qu'un jeune homme de 22 ans peut-être
que même si il est très doué au foot et
ma politiquement c'est un peu plus
compliqué pour lui de comprendre tous
les enjeux donc il y a ça aussi à
prendre en compte et je pense qui est
très important avant de crier au
scandale parce que Mbappé a pas pris la
bonne décision ou c'est pas exprimer sur
un sujet qui nous nous paraît essentiel
Lucas je le rassouille tout le monde ce
mouvement tatane que vous avez lancé
créé en 2011 ça continue il y a pas mal
et ça agrège pas mal de d'anciens
joueurs de foot Emmanuel Petit ancien
champion du monde il y en a beaucoup
d'autres et puis aussi des hommes
politiques d'aller le Cohn-Bendit par
exemple sur les noms que j'ai sous les
yeux pourquoi tatane et à quoi
aujourd'hui on est alors on est parti
sur quelque chose de pour parler à tout
le monde voilà le football business
un peu compliqué les gens se
désintéresser un peu on s'est dit il
faut parler un peu à tout le monde et
sans critiquer sans exclure le foot
business moi je viens de là et puis ça
va plus on va vers les quartiers
populaires à aider les gamins notamment
leur donner confiance voilà créer faire
du lien social grâce au football et on
va continuer à créer des événements
aussi on essaie c'est de mélanger les
gens faire en sorte que les gens se
croisent se parlent se voient rigolent
le foot c'est génial quoi c'est Fabius
pour le foot est-ce qu'il a un problème
avec le cette Coupe du Monde au Qatar
est-ce que le monde du football a un
problème avec le monde du Qatar le monde
politique semble commencer à avoir un
problème peut-être après coup c'est
peut-être un débat qu'on peut avoir
ensemble mais ça tombe de responsable
politique et mettre plus que des
réserves sur cette Coupe du Monde du
Qatar est-ce que le monde du foot a un
problème avec cette coupe du monde au
Qatar là il y a pas que le monde du foot
mais en tout cas le monde du foot va en
avoir un parce que déjà quand on regarde
la totalité des dimensions de
l'attribution jusqu'à ce qui va se
passer on va être confronté à une
quantité de problèmes il y a la question
environnementale il y a la question des
droits humains il y a la question des
droits des travailleurs et c'est la
première fois qu'on s'en en parle
médiatiquement avant on parlait pas des
droits des travailleurs il y a la
question aussi des minorités sur place
évidemment la question des femmes et on
est sur aujourd'hui des problématiques
qui accompagnent ces événements et là
enfin on a un vrai mouvement et pas que
politique mais aussi populaire qui vise
à mettre la pression sur la Fédération
internationale pour qu'elle bouge et les
fédérations nationales on a vu la FFF la
Fédération Française de foot est très
embêtée sur la question et avancer
manière à droite sur cette question à
comparer à d'autres fédérations la
Fédération allemande par exemple on a vu
les joueurs pendant un match
éliminatoire porter tous un t-shirt
Human Rights qui sont de culture de
génération est-ce qu'on a un peu en
dessous nous un peu timide par rapport à
cette coupe du monde sur le
Qatar aujourd'hui
que je lis des papiers notamment dans
France foot qui dénoncent les conditions
d'attribution de cette coupe du monde et
j'ai l'impression qu'on serait qu'on se
réveille un petit peu un peu tard parce
corruption on va le rappeler
exactement mais bon effectivement France
foot on parle depuis bonne dizaine
d'années et là on se réveille à un mois
de la compétition je vois pas bien
effectivement il y aura des actions qui
seront faites pendant la coupe du monde
mais je pense pas que la FIFA marche
arrière maintenant
qu'un jour 10 jours du début de la
compétition ou en pleine compétition il
y a des actions là le week-end dernier
il y a des supporters allemands qui ont
déployé des banderoles dans des stades
pour dire leur opposition à cette Coupe
du monde en Norvège aussi il y a eu des
actions notamment de la sélection des
supporters aussi on entend des voix qui
s'élèvent contre cette coupe du monde
mais moi je me pose la question pour
ceux qui sont contre et qui voilà est-ce
qu'il y a pas des choses à faire avant
et c'est pas une fois qu'on a le nez
dedans qu'il faut se dire bah on y va
plus alors c'est très bien on peut
penser qu'il y aura des gestes de
certains joueurs de certaines équipes
pendant cette Coupe du Monde au Qatar je
serai très surprise que ce soit le cas
mais on a la pédant ça paraît compliqué
parce que d'abord ça mettrait le joueur
ou les joueurs concernés en porte-à-faux
ça entraînerait probablement une
réaction de la FIFA et là on serait
vraiment sur un geste politique il y
aura un vrai encadrement par contre a
priori en dehors il devrait pouvoir
avoir une certaine liberté on a vu que
la Fédération allemande par exemple la
Fédération anglaise avait prévu
d'envoyer leurs joueurs justement à la
rencontre des travailleurs sur place on
les on a vu des ONG aussi proposer leurs
services à commencer par ramener ce
international sur le sujet et on sait
que les fédérations européennes vont
elles faire l'effort justement notamment
la Fédération danoise d'accompagner les
joueurs pour qu'il conscientise
finalement ce qui se passe au Qatar donc
on aura des choses après faut pas
s'attendre à avoir les joueurs avec le
genou à terre
revendiquer sur place ça paraît
compliqué puisquage de râteaux on fait
un peu de politique fiction vous faites
partie de la liste de Didier Deschamps
vous participez à cette Coupe du Monde
au Qatar qui est juste devant nous
je sais pas si je l'aurais eu en tout
cas récemment la FIFA quand même envoyé
une lettre à toutes les fédérations pour
dire on fait plus de politique
maintenant on passe au foot sans
injonction sans menaces il y a un truc
quand même où elle est un peu peur de ce
qui pourrait arriver et que peut-être
des joueurs vont s'émanciper la FIFA
pour la première fois de son histoire
officiellement a fait la politique en
excluant la Russie de toute compétition
officielle c'est voilà c'est de la vraie
politique là c'est une vraie prise de
position juste ou pas juste en tout cas
elle le fait en tout cas notre
fédération à nous elle est pas qu'elle
est timide c'est qu'elle est mauvaise
le grec sur toutes les prises de
position homophobie sexisme raciste il
est mauvais et la dernière fois sur le
Qatar c'est juste le mec qui il est hors
sol quoi et il est encore présent la
Fédération Française de Football
ailleurs je pense que ça ne passerait
pas ce genre de propos complètement
aberrant vous dites d'ailleurs dans
votre tribune que j'ai cité tout à
l'heure dans Libération c'est un pays où
les droits pour l'IVG sont menacés
aujourd'hui ou la peine de mort
vaut dans un certain état aujourd'hui
aux États-Unis
quels sont les critères de choix pour la
FIFA est-ce qu'il y a pas matière à
mettre un peu d'éthique dans tout cela
alors normalement quand on candidate
pour une compétition il y a des cahiers
des charges à remplir or les cahiers des
charges il sert juste à exclure certains
acteurs et à orienter quand on prend par
exemple le Qatar il avait le plus
mauvais dossier il a quand même été
choisi parce que d'ailleurs sur le
processus de désignation là en
l'occurrence à l'époque c'était le
comité exécutif de la Fifa qui décidait
et on a vu qu'aujourd'hui plus un seul
de ces acteurs dedans le football ils
sont tous tombés pour malversation
corruption et autres ça dit quelque
chose après la justice suit son cours et
donc elle tranchera mais sur la question
de l'attribution aujourd'hui on est sur
la vraie politique c'est à dire que là
on est sur de la géopolitique au sens
strict on est sur des rapports de force
internationaux et si les États-Unis ont
eu la Coupe du Monde 2026 on sait
pourquoi ils ont déjà paniqué quand il y
avait eu le Maroc face à eux
on sait aussi que si la FIFA a été
décapitée ce qu'on appelait le scandale
de la FIFA en 2014-2015 c'est parce que
les Etats-Unis ont extra territorialisé
leur justice on fait ce qu'il fallait
pour faire partir ce qui n'avaient pas
été en leur faveur en décembre 2010 au
moment où la Coupe du Monde a été
attribué au Qatar concrètement il
pouvait pas en être autrement les
États-Unis devaient avoir cette coupe du
monde ça tombe bien ils l'ont eu la
suite c'est la Chine on va voir certains
nombre de grandes villes françaises dont
Paris ont décidé de ne pas mettre des
grands géants pour regarder les les
matchs de foot de cette Coupe du Monde
finalement c'est les fans les
spectateurs qui vont payer
le prix du choix de la FIFA au Qatar
pour cette grande Qatar qu'est-ce qu'on
peut dire de ça je pense que grand monde
dehors en plein hiver donc c'est enfin
pour moi c'est de la c'est de la poudre
rose aux yeux encore une fois je moi je
suis contente que les gens
prennent la parole et s'élève s'ils
estiment que le Qatar ne mérite pas
cette coupe du monde mais je m'interroge
sur le timing enfin ça fait des années
qu'on sait que ce sera le Qatar ça fait
des années qu'on sait que la compétition
a été déplacée de l'été à l'hiver et que
ça bouge le calendrier notamment des
championnats européens on va voir ce que
ça va donner sur la deuxième partie de
saison parce que ça fait un carnage au
niveau des joueurs on les a pas
consultés on sait pas physiquement
comment ils vont encaisser ce qui va se
passer là la compétition qui est quand
même la compétition peut-être avec le
plus d'intensité au monde donc encore
une fois je trouve que des joueurs ont
été mis de côté alors comme quoi il y
aura pas que les spectateurs qui
essaient d'être lésés pour cette
compétition les gens vont la suivre quoi
qu'il arrive parce que c'est une coupe
du monde c'est pas grave c'est pas dans
une fan zone en tout cas je pense que ce
sera suivi mais voilà des choses quand
même qui qui dérangent au final
la Coupe du monde en 78 avec le
dictateur
on a d'autres cas comme ça où on a eu
quelques états d'âme tout de même 2018
souvenez-vous de Vladimir Poutine qui
touche le trophée la Coupe du monde et
qui applaudi par le vestiaire des Bleus
au moment où il entre les Bleus ils
viennent d'être champion du monde et ils
applaudissent venu un Poutine
aujourd'hui ces images là vous avez un
peu de mal qu'on voulait regarder hors à
l'époque on a réussi avait déjà envoyé
la Crimée avait déjà finalement
remis en cause le droit international et
la souveraineté l'Ukraine bon bah il
suffit de regarder l'histoire des coupes
du monde il y en a pas beaucoup qui soit
exemplaire vous allez la regarder cette
Coupe du Monde oui je vais la regarder
je vais travailler pour pour l'équipe et
canal je vais commenter voilà on est on
est conscient de ce qui se passe là-bas
on va quand les sujets arriveront si on
veut discuter
tout ça on ira puis j'irai à fond avec
le petit honnête était possible mais je
je remarque aussi que tu appelles à
boycott et tout ça c'est quand même les
pays du Nord les pays riches qui
j'aurais bien savoir ce qui se passe en
Afrique on en dit ou en Amérique du Sud
par exemple des pays moins moins
favorisés que que les nôtres
vous avez une réponse à ça comment
commencer perçu c'est le coupe du monde
s'il y a un vrai choc de représentation
c'est à dire que ce qu'on voit
véritablement c'est que en Europe et
finalement l'Amérique du Nord ce qu'on
appelait l'Occident avant
il y a un vrai problème avec cette coupe
du monde quand on va discuter j'ai fait
beaucoup d'émissions beaucoup
d'interviews notamment avec des
journalistes africains avec des journées
asiatiques et on se rend compte d'une
chose c'est qu'il y a une vraie
différence de perception d'abord parce
que c'est rare de voir les pays
africains arriver en Coupe du monde et
il y en a pas assez
en Asie la question elle se pose pas
parce que une majorité des pays sont des
régimes autoritaires et que toutes ces
questions là elles n'arrivent pas jusque
citoyens de base et que aujourd'hui il y
a une vraie volonté de voir cette Coupe
du Monde de la suivre et pas forcément
de la politisée comme nous on le ferait
on arrive à la fin de cette émission on
n'a pas parlé de l'Iran et pourtant il y
a eu un geste politique très fort de la
part des de l'équipe des footballeurs
hommes Iraniens qui ont caché leur
maillot national à l'occasion d'un match
qui se déroulait entre Sénégal en
Autriche entre le Sénégal Autriche à
Vienne là aussi c'est un bel exemple de
mobilisation politique cette fois pour
les femmes iraniennes et le combat
qu'elles sont en train de mener et
qu'elle mèneront peut-être d'ailleurs
durant cette Coupe du Monde il y a des
associations qu'on demande des
associations iraniennes qu'on demandait
à ce que l'équipe d'Iran soit exclus de
la Coupe du Monde qui ont fait une
demande officielle auprès de la FIFA
priori ce sera pas entendu mais
effectivement il y a des alors le geste
du manteau noir n'a pas été expliqué par
les joueurs mais on a déduit que c'était
ça il y a des anciens footballeurs qui
s'engagent comme Ali Hakimi qui poste
des choses sur les réseaux sociaux des
messages tous les jours exactement
respecter là-bas à l'idée aussi qui est
très longtemps été le meilleur buteur de
l'histoire des sélections voilà il y a
des choses qui se passent alors c'est un
peu plus compliqué pour les footballeurs
actuelles de prendre position parce que
voilà avec tout ce que ça peut
entraîner derrière on sait que pour le
régime là-bas s'il y a un footballeur
s'exprime c'est pris comme une
opposition à la nation iranienne donc
c'est très très compliqué pour eux pour
leurs proches mais il y a des
footballeurs qui le font à Lidl c'est vu
confisquer c'est son passeport par
exemple pour avoir
osé critiquer la manière dont étaient
déterrétées le peuple iranien donc voilà
les footballeurs iraniens le s'engagent
s'exprime à leur niveau ils le font et
c'est important parce qu'ils seront
peut-être vecteurs d'un changement dans
ce pays actuellement où il se passe
beaucoup de choses merci vraiment à tous
les trois on a passé un bon moment pour
parler de des footballeurs et et de la
politique et de leur investissement sur
le terrain politique vos réactions ça
sera sur hashtag débat doc sur Twitter
je compte sur vous trois pour réagir à
ce que seront ces réactions parce que
mon avis elle risque de pas manquer
après cette cette émission merci à celle
massali également qui m'a aidé à
préparer cette émission comme à
l'accoutumée puis moi je vous donne
rendez-vous pour un prochain débat doc
et ça sera bien sûr avec son
documentaire et son débattre bientôt
[Musique]